this military convoy in northern Italy
is carrying a grim cargo 30 coffins with
the bodies of 30 coronavirus victims
headed to a small village for cremation
because there are too many covert 19
dead in the nearby city of Bergamo and
with italy recording its deadliest day
of the outbreak yet with another nearly
800 deaths there could be more convoys
like this needed Spain now has the third
highest number of infections worldwide
with around 25,000 the death toll is
past 1,300 now
to help Madrid and Barcelona are
converting exhibition centers into field
hospitals for the sick Germany has had a
spike in confirmed cases up to more than
16 and a half thousand and there are now
temporary fences on its border with
Switzerland the German government is
considering whether to bring in a full
nationwide ban on going outside where
much of Europe has already gone with its
lockdown and social distancing measures
the UK is following economically
culturally and socially this is a
country that has been transformed in
just a few days by order of the
government's the UK is now pretty much
closed pubs cafes restaurants gyms
museums nursery schools and universities
all shut for the foreseeable future the
Capitals buses and metro system are
empty don't use them unless your job is
critical people in London are being told
this usually teeming metropolis is quiet
well I think it's good news I think it's
good news in terms of that they're
looking after people that are losing out
on their wages the fact that they're
they're stopping hopefully or spreading
by closing down the restaurants yeah I
think I think they've done the right
thing we went out last night for the
last hour and sort of tipped up a little
bit higher than we should have I suppose
so just to sort of keep people going
along and it's sad for the smaller
businesses but hopefully the government
will kick in and sort of support people
along the government is trying to stop a
wave of panic buying that has stripped
supermarket shelves bare this week be
responsible when you shop and think of
others buying more than you need means
that others may
be left without and it is making life
more difficult for those frontline
workers such as our doctors and nurses
and NHS support staff who are working so
hard in such difficult circumstances to
prevent total collapse the government
will prop up businesses and guarantee
80% of all wages it's an unprecedented
temporary nationalization of the UK's
economy
Rory challon's al-jazeera London